الى تطورات الميدانيه في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اذ اعلنت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه تصديه قوتها لاكثر من 100 هجوم
روسي خلال يوم واحد على جبهات بخموت ولمان
وافديفكا ومارينكا وشختر شرقي اوكرانيا في
المقابل قالت القوات المواليه لروسيا فيزا
ان عشرات ممن وصفتهم بالمرتزقه الاجانب
قتلوا في ضربه روسيه وسط المدينه
معنا من كرامه
مسعود ومن موسكو ايضا يبقى معنا امين
درغامي وابدا ايضا معك مره اخرى امين فيما
يتعلق بها التطور خاصه ما نقل عن القوات
المواليه لروسيا ومقامت به
نعم عبد القادر
الاداره العسكريه والمدنيه الروسيه في
مقاطعه اعلنت عن مقتل العشرات مما قالت
انهم مرتزقه اجانب كانوا باحد المراكز
مراكز الايواء المؤقته في مدينه وذلك في
ضرب في ضربه عسكريه
للقوات الروسيه على مجمع فندقي في مدينه
لم تكشف عن السلاح الذي استخدمه جيش
الروسي هل هو صواريخ من طراز كاليبر ام
طائرات مسيره ام غيرها لكن من يعني ما
اكدته هو ان من بين
القتلى
الاجانب من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مواطنين من الولايات المتحده ومن بولندا
وايضا من بريطانيا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
في بيانها اليوم تحدثت عن استهدافات ايضا
عبد القادر في عدد من المحاور ابرزها محور
دونياتك ومحور دونيتك الجنو اضافه الى
محور كوبيانسك في مقاطعه خارقيب تحدثت عن
مقتل اكثر من 350 عسكريا اوكرانيا خلال
يوم واحد فقط في تلك الاستهدافات تحدثت
ايضا عن اسقاط تسع طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه
وخمسه عشر صاروخا من طراز
وايضا صواريخ اخرى اضافه الى استهداف عدد
من مراكز
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه خاصه في
مقاطعه اما في ضخمه التي ما زالت كما نعلم
تشهد معارك محتدمه بين الجيش الاوكراني
والقوات الروسيه وخاصه قوات فاجنر ما زالت
هناك محاولات لبسط سيطره قوات فاجنر بشكل
كامل على المنطقه الصناعيه التي الان
تتركز فيها المعارك بعد ان كانت مصادر
اعلاميه روسيه قد اكدت في وقت سابق
اعلى ان قوات تمكنت من السيطره على مواقع
مهمه داخل هذه المنطقه وايضا تقوم
بهجوم على مركز مدينه مركز عفوا مدينه
ضخموت من محورين المحور الشمالي وايضا
المحور الجنوبي فيما يبدو انه محاوله
لاطباق طوق حول مدينه بخموت ومحاصرتها
بشكل كامل وايضا بتزامن مع هجوم مازال
متواصلا على بلده خروموفا التي تقع على
الطريق طريق الامداد الاخير للجيش
الاوكراني والذي يربط بين مدينتي باخموت
وتشيسوفير المجاوره
حسان كنت اراك تلتفت يمينا ويسارا هل هناك
غاره في هذه الاثناء
نعم عبد القادر قبل دقائق فقد سمعنا اصوات
قصف في مدينه كرماتورس تحديدا من الجهه
الجنوبيه من هذه المدينه اصوات القصف كانت
قويه جدا يبدو انها عبر سلسله من الضربات
الصاروخيه اصابت جنوب منطقه اكراماتوروسك
حتى هذه اللحظه لا نستطيع من موقعنا ان
نحدد المكان بدقه الذي كنا سمعنا فيه
اصوات الانفجارات هذه الضربه الصاروخيه
تاتي بعد ضربات صاروخيه ايضا كانت قد
تعرضت لها منطقه كوستانتينيكا الواقعه غرب
منطقه بخموت وهذه المنطقه المنطقه التي
تقع غرب بخموت والمدن الرئيسيه فيها تتعرض
بالتوازي مع استمرار المعارك في منطقه
بخمت لضربات مكثفه طيله الليل وخلال
النهار
لمحاوله منع القوات الاوكرانيه من مواصله
التقدم عبر هذه المدن باتجاه منطقه بخمو
تلك الجبهه التي ما مشتعله القصف في
محيطها
والمعارك بداخلها مازالت مستمره كما ان
هيئه الاركان تحدثت اليوم عن احباطها
لمحاولات التفاف وهجوم عند الجهه الجنوبيه
الغربيه لمنطقه باخمت بتحديدا باتجاه بلده
ايفانوريسك هذه البلده التي تقع وسط
الطريق الرئيسيه الواصله ما بين منطقه
كوستانتيني
وهذه المنطقه تتعرض لمحاولات حديثه من قبل
القوات الروسيه للتقدم نحو نحوها لقطع طرق
الامداد باتجاه منطقه بخمت الا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول انها ما زالت تواصل
المعارك هناك تنشر عددا من المقاطع التي
تقول انها حديثه للمعارك هناك لقصف القوات
الاوكرانيه والمدفعيه لقوات فاجنر في تلك
المناطق تحديدا عند جبهه باخموت وحتى في
ذات الوقت نحن مازلنا نرصد مد القوات في
منطقه بخموت بالاليات المدرعات وكذلك
بالافراد الذين يبدو انهم اتوا حديثا
للتوجه الى منطقه باخموت عبر الطرقات
الواصله ما بين منطقه كراماتورز
بعدها باتجاه بخموت هذه المنطقه مشتعله من
الناحيه العسكريه كما من ناحيه القصف
والقصف المتبادل القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا
تقصف من هذه المناطق المناطق تمركز القوات
الروسيه نلاحظ يوما بعد اخر ان القوات
الروسيه تحاول التقدم باتجاه هذه الطرقات
ونرصد عبر مواقع رصد
التحركات عند الجبهات التي تعتمدها القوات
الاوكرانيه محاوله فعليه للتقدم باتجاه
هذه المناطق لكن يبدو ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت تقوم بصد هذه الهاشمات
الهيئه العليا للاركان تحدثت عن صدها ل
100 هجمه اليوم ليس فقط هنا في باقه انما
ايضا على مختلف الجبهات ش رقيه البلاد
شكرا لك حسن مسعود من كراماتورسك